to everybody listening people in uniform
people in business suits people in
coveralls people everyone we talk today
about Mikey Mansoor I don't want to
leave you with this
Mikey monster was named after Saint
Michael Saint Michael is the warrior Ark
Angel that led heavens army against
Satan Saint Michael was known as the
principal of the angelic Warriors and
was seen as a protector against the
darkness and in the Christian religion
specifically in the Anglican and the
Catholic and the Lutheran churches
September 29th September 29th is known
as Michael Mass or Saint Michael's day
and that day September 29th 2006 was the
day that our Saint Michael
Mikey Mansour was killed in Iraq the
city of Ramadi sacrificing his life to
save the lives of three of his teammates
three of his brothers three of his
friends and I would ask you this when
September 29th comes around remember
and I would ask that while you honor the
hero and you honor the warrior that
Michael Monsoor was please also remember
that Mikey was a person he was a smiling
kid he was a jokester he was a
determined man a brother a son an uncle
a friend and Michael Monsoor was a young
man with hopes and plans and aspirations
and dreams dreams
for his future and dreams for his life
and in that moment of truth he gave them
all all those hopes and all those dreams
he gave them all to us remember that
you